it's January Paranormal Activity the
marked ones this is the first wide
release coming out in 2014 the first
movie I'm reviewing in 2014 and
Hollywood seems to be following a very
similar trend lately the first movie
that release in January tends to be a
horror film last year we had Texas
Chainsaw 3d in years past we had one
missed call the unborn The Devil Inside
and we're doing it again this year a
common trend with all of them is that
they suck this one follows in that same
path so in this movie we have these two
buddies and of course they film
everything that happens because if they
didn't film everything that happens you
wouldn't have a movie their downstairs
neighbor is this creepy lady and she
dies and they decided to go down there
and investigate what happens and this
one guy becomes mark she like becomes
marked by some sort of strange entity
that it actually gives him superhero
powers and this movie is really dumb and
what I'm talking about dumb I'm talking
about these characters are so dumb their
first initial thought when their
downstairs neighbor is murdered after
the police leave is to go in there with
their cameras and touch everything and
the crime scene just they touch
everything print everything and
incriminate themselves in the process of
course they don't have to worry about
that though because this is paranormal
activity the marked ones where nothing
makes sense when this guy realizes that
he has all these powers all of a sudden
and that something seems to be following
him around he thinks it's amazing like
he all of a sudden can drop and just
floating he doesn't actually land he
never actually questions it he just he's
like whoa oh this is awesome I mean he
starts like talking to this thing
through that Simon gamer that old Simon
game the musical he had to remember the
buttons and everything yeah the thing
starts like talking back to him they
just don't think it's so cool I mean
they think it's the greatest thing ever
and they never seem to question the fact
that this is not normal my friend but
basically what this movie is is a scene
to scene build up to a very loud jump
scare and generally it's a false scare
where a guy comes out of something goes
well I got Joe and that's really all we
have here there are a couple of cool
scenes in the movie where the guy gets
these powers and he can do stuff and it
looked cool on screen and everything
there isn't really anything about the
movie that's scary it's just you're
anticipating a very loud booming noise
that will jolt you because is
loud as hell that's not scary it's just
it's just sound effects there's an
element to this movie that is really
dumb and stupid and it's really the main
thing that bothers me and it's a spoiler
now look I do not recommend that you
guys see this movie it is a very dumb
movie so I'm going to give you a very
big spoiler warning here because I'm
gonna tell you this thing because I just
can't do this review without expressing
it this was a better movie I would not
spoil it but this is a awful movie I've
given you a fair spoiler warning about
the ending of this film if you don't
want to know about it that's okay don't
see this movie though please they decide
to use time travel to connect this film
with the others
time travel how stupid is that
Paranormal Activity the marked ones is a
film that I cannot call scary despite
the fact that there were moments in the
movie where I went but simply that's
because there's a loud noise that
there's just a loud noise that's not
scary there's no real tension or fright
to that it's just you don't want to be
startled by this loud ear piercing noise
the characters in this movie are so
idiotic and so stupid and the ending is
just dumb I'm gonna give paranormal
activity the mark one Zadi I'm not
giving it an F because there are a
couple cool scenes where he has these
powers and everything but this is not a
good movie don't check it out I mean
it's the first movie in January what do
you expect there's another one of these
coming out later this year fantastic so
guys what do you think of the Paranormal
Activity series what are some of your
favorite moments or films let me know
below as always guys thanks very much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck
Benoist
[Music]